bring in Justin Turner here Dodgers
third baseman my Dodgers by the way uh
Justin explained this to me could you
see the catch by the little leaguer in
centerfield where he went over the wall
and they called it an out yeah I did
that was a constant reddleman the full
speed running I don't even know if he
knew where the wall was it looked like
he just jumped to catch the ball and end
up flying over the wall and to do that
on national TV on that stage something
that he's going to probably have playing
in his house for the rest of his life
okay should it be an out though since he
caught the ball over the wall yeah
that's a good question
no well that's what we're trying to
figure out because it you play third
base if you catch the ball like you can
catch the ball and go into the stands in
foul territory and it's an out right
yeah but I don't you can't jump in the
stands and then catch the ball you have
to have you have to be in on the field
when you catch the ball so that's a
great question if he was up definitely
in the air and then caught the ball and
then flew over the wall yeah I mean I
guess technically that could have been a
homer yeah well that's I think it should
have been a home run we saw play at
Fenway a couple of weeks ago where you
had a player who went into the bullpen
and you know they called it an out even
though he fell into a homeland territory
all right let me get to the serious
stuff here you're leading the National
League in hitting do you how often do
you look at the newspaper to see where
you are with everybody else
well nowadays there's not very many
newspapers to look at okay here on your
iPad or your iPhone how often do you
just keep an eye on who's who's uh
tracking you down
I'm so bad uh no but I mean that's
substance everywhere you know you go you
go to different stadiums and they have
all the information flashing up but I
don't know who's buying me or how far
ahead I am or how close it is I'm just
you know trying to go and take as many
good at-bats I can and
and get on base as much as I can
especially with Bellinger hitting behind
me I feel like I'm in scoring position
if I can just get to first base so you
know it's a cool thing obviously
everything is going good but we still
got a lot of baseball left and to start
looking at it now I think would be doing
myself a disservice there a part of you
that wishes the playoffs started right
now aside from not having Kershaw there
but the way you guys have been playing
yeah you know even asked that a lot I
think you know with as many veterans as
we have we do have a lot of young guys
still and there's still room for
everyone to grow not just young guys I
think everyone can learn and get better
and try to figure out what we're trying
to do here and the amount of information
that this game has to offer now is crazy
and I think we're kind of on the on the
brink of grasping it and how to turn
numbers into information that you can
actually use on the field and our
coaching staff has been unbelievable so
I think you know this last you know
month or so we're going to take the time
and take advantage of trying to get
better with all the information we have
and how we can put it to use and how we
can how we can make it help us win games
on a field in the class he's Justin
Turner he's leading the National League
he was an all-star leading the National
League and hitting what explained to me
after right before that 2014 season it's
a pretty amazing story though when you
consider you you were let go by the Mets
and then you're just sort of floating
out there and then you end up with the
Dodgers like how do you how do you put
all that together if you were trying to
explain it to somebody yeah that was a
that was a tough time for me I was
actually heading down to the Players
Association meetings in San Diego as of
representative for the Mets and on my
way down I got the phone call from sandy
saying that they needed some roster
space and they wish they were you know
letting me go and non-tender me and you
know that offseason was hard I would get
calls from my agent every other day
saying oh this seems interested this
thing
interested and then nothing would come
of it and you know you hear a team name
and you get excited and you start you
know looking at their roster and their
stuff and then the next day that team's
out of it and it was a brutal process
and at the end it came down to it
actually came down to the Red Sox and
twins and I was getting close to make a
decision and Marlon Byrd called me and
he was good friends with Michael Young
who was with the Dodgers at the time and
he was trying to make a decision on
whether he was going to come back and
play one more year or whether he was
going to retire so Marlon called me and
said hey don't sign anywhere yet if
Michael Young decides to retire
I think the Dodgers are going to call
you oh man and sure enough I think a
couple days later Michael decided he
want to spend time with the family and
then my phone rang and and the doctor
called if I would have told you at that
time when the Dodgers called a by the
way you're going to start and you're
going to lead the National League in
hitting one year yeah that'd have been
hard too hard to see at that time I was
going through some stuff making some
changes in my swing and trying to get
better but that that definitely would
have it hard to see how good were used a
little leaguer I think I was a good
player I don't think I was a standout
guy I was always small in my junior high
school I was only five nine hundred
thirty pounds so I never really stuck
out on the field I had to take advantage
of trying to be as smart as I could and
be a baseball player to get noticed and
then eventually you know through college
and when I got pro ball I started being
a little bit bigger and stronger and and
the ball started going a little further
for me I love the story about ed sheeran
who was at Staples in any warrior Jersey
out for an encore there this just feels
like ginger on ginger love there okay
right is that what you you see with that
cheer yeah that was crazy I actually had
no idea he was doing that we were trying
to reach out to him cuz we knew it was
in LA we knew we were in LA we were
trying to get him to come to the stadium
come to a game or at least come in the
clubhouse and
and talked to some guys and it didn't
end up working out and then next thing I
know you know we get in the locker room
from the game and my phone has a million
messages on it saying the edge here is
wearing your Jersey for the Encore
playing shape of you right now at the
Staples Center I'm like what and then I
get all these videos and pictures and
text and yeah it was pretty crazy and
they did begin the next night so
definitely feel pretty honored about
that and hopefully I'll get to go see
them in concert one day make is this
your walk-up song yeah when did you tell
your song from day one this year I've
been using it so I heard of the thought
season liked it obviously he's a ginger
so I was like this is it this is this is
what we're going with this here so it
couldn't worked out any better yeah but
you strike me a little more hardcore
music than than Ed Sheeran I kid I do
you like metal you know rock and roll
I like everything I don't love metal but
I'll listen to a Brandon McCarthy when
he works out play some pretty heavy
stuff and yeah I'm probably the only guy
on the team that doesn't mind it but I
like everything I don't I don't
discriminate I if as long as there's a
beat to it I'll listen to it all I
played music all the time in the
clubhouse and four guys and I try to
cover all the genres and keep everyone
happy so yeah well that's why you're the
team leader hey yeah I guess Hey
Congrats on the success so far and
certainly a great moment in your career
not exactly an overnight sensation but
it feels like that for you but Congrats
on the all-star game and right now the
season you're having we appreciate your
time Justin I think there's I'm young
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience